Hey Conan O'Brien here well here's the
good news I'm in my 25th year as a
late-night host started out in 1993 25
years still going strong
everything's terrific but there's one
problem nobody talks about what if
something were to happen to me I know
they'll get upset I live kind of a fast
dangerous life and I have a lot of
enemies so I could go at any time that's
why I've been thinking about a
replacement someone young virile who can
step in and is ready to be the next
Conan O'Brien ladies and gentlemen meet
David hoppin David step on in here hey
David hey and you've been working for me
for how long you're gonna have now year
and a half yeah okay where you from
David Southern Illinois
John named Carlinville okay didn't
really ask about the time I need there
to be someone waiting in the wings to
step in as Conan O'Brien should that be
necessary
okay and I thought you're a young guy
you seem very likable would you like to
be the next Conan O'Brien why not why
not what you like
what about oh my god I don't think I
could do that that's insane
please up here and I'm down here why did
you just act like this is no big deal
what you don't seem it all in aa
who me I can't pull the sword out of the
stone and be King Arthur it seems easy
to you doesn't it to fill in for Conan
O'Brien no what do you mean you don't
know you think you can just step into my
shoes just be me you need training okay
I'm sorry I yelled at you okay are you a
fan of my comedy I am just gonna I'm
sorry no not like wow yes you meant a
lot to me as a kid you did
if you're gonna be Conan O'Brien I need
to know that you are fit healthy you're
gonna live a long long time let's go
through it cardiovascular system any
heart problems nope any problems with
her liver pancreas gallbladder or hernia
no are you pregnant
no have you used LSD heroin cocaine or
any other narcotic depressant stimulant
or psychedelic whether or not prescribed
by a physician within the last five
years no you haven't used any of those
cocaine LSD no uppers no down or swim
Benny blue jacket regulars and you have
a pleasant odor okay follow my finger
yeah let's get you looking like me shall
we let's do it okay I'm told that David
is ready with his makeover David
[Music]
[Applause]
you might wanna know Brian thank you
yeah how do you feel good ah what are
you excited to look this way the rest of
your life yeah I'm being totally honest
I'm attracted to you right now I'm just
saying that not in a sexual way
I guess what other way is there now the
first thing we're gonna do was learn how
to act like Conan O'Brien around the
office okay you ready for that
ready so no what do you think it's very
creepy you look like you that's
fantastic
I'm now gonna teach David how to
interact with you sona okay you have a
very specific kind of chemistry okay
it's a little dysfunctional okay what
usually happens is I walk in and sona
what are you usually watching on your
computer screen honestly uh right now
I'm binge watching Cheers
you're watching an NBC show from 35
years ago let's say I needed a
prescription yes
what would come first you getting me the
prescription are you finishing the
cheers episode of be honest this is you
need that prescription Sona I need that
prescription you want you cheers
everyone you're seeing on your screen
right now is dead okay
Sona
sprint danger I demand a note I demand
to know who's printed what grab these
papers and hold them in her face and say
you forget something while I was talking
yeah go you printed these while I was
talking that's outlandish unheard of
I said balderdash because as you know
I'm not getting any younger
you said it no that's your cue and
saying what are you talking about what
are you to look like a friendly guy
without knowing their name as I call
everybody chopper ok hey Dad chopper hey
man chopper
we're gonna go in and talk to the
writers now their meeting okay the way I
usually do it as I kick open the door
okay I make a lot of kind of silly
over-the-top jokes about how horrible
the writings been lately even when it's
been good last time I saw a [ __ ] pile of
this I was in a barnyard
I always leave the room on a huge laughs
so take care of that so on you pieces of
[ __ ] face your biggest challenge which
is to talk to Jordan slansky so you're
trying to make him than you look like
you know he is the new Cohen okay he's
gonna be trained to be the new comers
the intent that he would fool someone
and they wouldn't notice the switch
she's just gonna be combed let's just
see if we can recreate some of our
classic chemistry what do you do here at
the Conan show I have various
administrative tasks what does that even
mean there are certain logistical
matters that need to be attended to
notice it's best to be nice and sweep
everything here onto the floor at home
just so it's as fragile though it's
probably not done calm which is an
Italian brand of porcelain and Lavazza
espresso cups you used to be mm
breakfast wanton violence that leads to
nothing
I had acid right now I pour it in your
eyes live you know being Conan O'Brien
it's a thrill for people to see me okay
say hey folks aunt bugs
say come on Brian hello woman what's
your name what's your name you well
you're a big fan of his yeah a big fan
of his he's the new Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
[Music]
that's oh I'm gonna go I'm so sorry he
did that too he's sick man
[Applause]
chase the tram now and say I'm really
needy I'm really needy I'm really needy
needy I need more laughter this laughter
makes up for my home life
well David we spent a couple of hours
with each other I've tried to teach you
everything I can there's just one last
test you ready ready all right you have
to kill me guess what you just passed
you just passed the test the weird test
yeah where's Simon David hopping the new
Conan
[Music]
Plus every day
[Applause]
that's a big part of the job
congratulations it's gonna be big for
you we'll be right back
say who's coming on we'll be right back
with DJ Callie
[Applause]
you